Energien und jetzt ist der
Bundesgesundheitsminister dran Karl
Lauterbach zusammen mit Professor
Michael Hallig er ist der Vorsitzende
des Sachverständigenrates zu Entwicklung
im Gesundheitswesen und die beiden
wollen jetzt ihre Pläne zur
Digitalisierung im Gesundheitswesen
vorstellen es geht konkret um den
Neustart der elektronischen Patienten
Akte das ist ja sozusagen ein ewiges
Projekt was nie zum Einsatz kam jetzt im
Zuge der Digitalisierung soll das einen
Neustart erfahren
bisher haben nur ein Prozent aller
Deutschen überhaupt eine elektronische
Patientenakte und das soll jetzt bis
Ende 2024 sich deutlich ändern alle
Deutschen sollen eine elektronische
Patientenakte bekommen außer sie lehnen
das ausdrücklich ab und die Pläne des
Ministers die hören wir jetzt frei zu
machen damit uns
auch alle sehen können ich begrüße Sie
zu dieser Bundespressekonferenz sogar
die
Digitalisierungsstrategie für Gesundheit
und Pflege dazu begrüße ich den
Bundesminister für Gesundheit Professor
Dr Karl Lauterbach und ich begrüße
professor Michael harlek den Vorsitzende
Sachverständigenrates zur Begutachtung
der Entwicklung im Gesundheitswesen
vielen Dank pferdhoff zunächst dass wir
hier wieder in ihren Räumen und unter
ihrer Leitung tragen dürfen herzlich
willkommen auch Michael Hulk ich meine
Damen und Herren es geht heute um ein
sehr wichtiges Thema welches also leicht
unterschätzt wird und zwar die
Digitalisierung im deutschen
Gesundheitswesen hier haben wir wirklich
wahrscheinlich sogar mittlerweile
Jahrzehnte lange Rückstände wir haben
große Probleme in der Digitalisierung
und zwar sowohl in der Versorgung wie
aber auch also in der Forschung und das
ist also ein gravierendes Problem weil
Digitalisierung spielt in der Medizin
eine immer größere Rolle und also eine
wirklich gute Versorgung ist tatsächlich
ohne den Zugriff auf digitale
Patientendaten nicht mehr wirklich gut
darstellbar und
in der Forschung ist es selbstsprechend
dass also vieles einfach nur noch
möglich ist in dem digitale Daten zur
Verfügung stehen ausgewertet werden
können und dann in verschiedene Art und
Weise zusammengeführt werden können und
all diese in Deutschland nicht möglich
wir haben zwar eine elektronische
Patientenakte aber die Einführung ist so
schwierig und auch also vielleicht
kompliziert aufgesetzt dass weniger als
ein Prozent der also gesetzlich
versicherten Patienten überhaupt eine
elektronische Patientenakte haben und
diese wird dann in der Regel auch nicht
genutzt somit sind wir da überhaupt
nicht weitergekommen und also bei den
also elektronischen Daten die genutzt
werden könnten und Forschung zu machen
haben wir die Lage dass die Daten die es
gibt es gibt Daten dass die nicht
miteinander verknüpft werden können und
weil sie nicht miteinander verkn werden
können sind
Langzeitbeobachtungen und auch also
Beobachtungen wo man also Risikofaktoren
miteinander ausgleichen so dass es alles
nicht möglich somit sind diese Daten
ebenfalls nicht nutzbar somit zwei große
Probleme keine gelungene Digitalisierung
in der Behandlung und keine gelungene
Digitalisierung in der Forschung das ist
die Situation das ist in gewisser Weise
überraschend aber also die elektronische
Patientenakte und die Grundlagen dafür
sind ja schon vor mehr sind genau vor 20
Jahren geschaffen worden damals durch
Ulla Schmidt ich war an der also
Einführung damals beteiligt aber
tatsächlich ist es nie richtig umgesetzt
worden und wir sind derzeit in einer
Situation wo auch viele Ärztinnen und
Ärzte eine Art Defätismus entwickelt
haben dahingehend dass man gar nicht
weiß ob in Deutschland die
Digitalisierung überhaupt noch
angegangen werden soll oder nicht
den wollen wir jetzt also mit Druck
begegnen wir haben uns
sehr intensiv mit den Problemen
auseinandergesetzt wir haben zum
Beispiel auch die Frage analysiert
weshalb ist ein Unternehmen wie biontech
aus Deutschland weggegangen und da so
will seine klinischen Studien jetzt in
also England machen was ist das was wir
nicht anbieten können wir haben uns sehr
intensiv damit beschäftigt welche Daten
vielen eigentlich in der Praxis wenn
jemand behandelt und also will also
Patienten einstellen behandeln als
Facharzt es fehlen dann aber Befunde von
der Vorbehandlung und dergleichen sie
haben sehr genau analysiert was sind
eigentlich die also Probleme und der
präsentieren daher heute eine digital
Strategie die also schon seit Monaten
durch mein Team erarbeitet wird und also
wo wir klare Ziele erstmal definiert
haben was wollen wir jetzt kurzfristig
schaffen
um zu zeigen Digitalisierung geht in
Deutschland und da haben wir uns also
wenn man so will drei also Etappen Ziele
vorgenommen zunächst einmal dass wir bis
2025 80 Prozent der Versicherten mit
einer elektronischen Patienten aktuell
versehen haben wollen 80 Prozent also
das ist die Benchmark jetzt ein Prozent
das ist 80 Prozent zum zweiten wir
wollen also die wir wollen also
Ende 25
bei 80% der dann epa-nutzer wollen wir
also einen
medikationsübersicht haben dann
indikationsplan und also zum dritten wir
wollen bis Ende 26 schon an 300
Forschungsvorhaben Gesundheitsdaten aus
dem Gesundheits-
zusammengeführt haben somit hätten wir
dann die elektronische Patientenakte
aufgebaut wir hätten sie genutzt für die
elektronische für das elektronische
Rezept und den medikationsplan und wir
hätten dann auch für die also Forschung
hätten schon 300 Projekte die mit den
neuen also Datensystem ausgewertet
worden sind das sind also die Ziele und
also wie wollen wir das erreichen ja
durch zwei Gesetze das eine ist das
sogenannte
digitalgesetzes das Gesetz was sich
damit beschäftigt also ähm wie die Eva
also als
Variante
komme gleich dazu was das bedeutet also
eingeführt werden kann aber wie wir die
Ehepartner einführen und das zweite
Gesetz ist das
Gesundheitsdaten nutzungsgesetz und
dieses Gesundheitsamt nutzungsgesetz das
soll dafür sorgen dass die Daten die
sind in unserem System gibt neue Daten
und die bestehenden dass man die so
zusammenführen kann
das also tatsächlich auch longit und
longitudinale Auswertungen möglich sind
bei dieser also EPA im digitalgesetz ich
hatte es gerade schon gesagt ob
outvariante das bedeutet jeder ist
automatisch also Träger einer EPA es sei
denn er hat ausdrücklich widersprochen
somit das ist ein Automatismus man muss
sich nicht erst kompliziert bewerben
oder man muss sich nicht kompliziert
entscheiden für die Ehepaar sondern wenn
man nichts unternimmt dann ist man
trotzdem eh Verträge und dann kann in
diese EPA auch eingesperrt werden die
Eva soll dann so aufgebaut werden und
dass idealerweise der Patient werden
wenn er das möchte über seine
Krankenkassen App auch auf seiner Daten
zugreifen kann das sind ja seine Daten
das wird noch einmal viele Patienten
auch in eine ganz andere Situation
bringen also die die Daten die hat zu
nutzen aber jemand der das nicht machen
möchte das auch gut dann werden trotzdem
die Eva seine neuen Daten eingespeist
und also beim Kontakt mit dem Arzt wird
dann gibt er quasi dann schaltet er
quasi die EPA dann frei so dass der
behandelnde Arzt dann tatsächlich auf
die epa-daten zurückgreifen kann und das
bedeutet also alle Daten alle
Behandlungsdaten die benötigt werden zu
dem Zeitpunkt sind dann verfügbar also
aus meiner Sicht also
Sprung in der Verbesserung der
Versorgung und eine deutliche
Verbesserung bei der Datennutzung will
ich nur ein Beispiel nennen wir haben
also in Deutschland das ist also
krankenkassendaten wir haben also
Krebsregister Daten wir werden demnächst
also
genug Daten haben
wir also haben quasi Daten aus
unterschiedlichsten Quellen und also
durch dieses Gesundheitsdaten
nutzungsgesetz ist es dann möglich oder
über einem Zeug Film die also Daten
eines einzelnen Menschen
zusammenzuführen aus diesen
unterschiedlichen Bereichen so dass man
dann Auswertungen machen kann und der
Nutzung all diese Daten die Daten liegen
dezentral also ein sicheres System und
es ist auch kein Missbrauch dieser Daten
also möglich daher wollen wir diese
Daten verfügbar machen für
Wissenschaftler aber auch für die
Industrie so dass tatsächlich also hier
eine ganz andere Qualität der Versorgung
möglich ist dann sind wir weg von den
Datensilos die wir derzeit haben und
können die Daten zusammenbringen und
kommen also quasi zu einer anderen ganz
anderen
Versorgungsqualität auch
ich glaube dass man das was wir heute
vorstellen nicht unterschätzen sollte
werden wir hier
einen Durchbruch schaffen dann wird das
auch die praktische Medizin verändern
dann sind plötzlich alle Befunde eines
Patienten zu jedem Zeitpunkt dass sie
sind da
wenn eine telemedizinische Versorgung
durchgeführt wird dann können diese
Befunde genutzt werden
wenn also Forschung gemacht wird dann
sind wir in der Lage
Forschung zu machen wo wir einzelnen
Patienten also die Teilnahme an einer
Studie also empfehlen können weil wir
wissen dass Patienten dieser Art von
einer solchen Studie besonders
profitieren würden das hat aber für den
Bereich der Onkologie hat das große
Bedeutung ich bin ganz sicher dass
Kollege Michael harlek vielleicht gleich
noch darauf hinweisen wird aber das ist
tatsächlich etwas wo wir zurück gefallen
sind und wir mit also dem was wir hier
vorstellen machen wir die also
Versorgung besser die Forschung besser
und auch die Telemedizin besser somit
also wichtige Schritte nach vorne so
dass wir das Versprechen von also Ulla
Schmidt 20 Jahre alt dass wir dieses
Versprechen jetzt einlösen können vielen
Dank Herr Minister
ja ich freue mich sehr heute diese
diesen Entwurf mit unterstützen zu
dürfen ich will kurz was zu meiner Rolle
sagen ich bin hier einerseits als Arzt
und Forscher der seit fast drei
Jahrzehnten an Blutkrebs und an Krebs
forscht und dadurch versucht die
Behandlung weltweit zu verbessern und
außerdem bin ich seit kurzem der
Vorsitzende Sachverständigenrates und
insofern kann ich sagen dass viele
Empfehlungen des
sachverständigenratsgutachtens aus 2021
immer noch Gültigkeit haben und zu einem
nicht unwesentlichen Teil hier jetzt
umgesetzt werden und ich persönlich
unterstütze alle diese
zentralen Anliegen dieses damaligen
Gutachtens von vollem Herzen und freue
mich dass heute vieles davon in der
Umsetzung kommen könnte ich nenne ihn
mal ein Beispiel warum das so wichtig
ist zwei vielleicht
wir forschen in Köln an Lungenkrebs und
da gibt es verschiedene Netze wir haben
bestimmte Abkürzungen die spielen jetzt
keine Rolle aber Lungenkrebs ist heute
eine Erkrankung die ist erstens immer
noch extrem häufig und sie ist zweitens
immer stärker molekular charakterisiert
man weiß also schaltermoleküle und kann
die dann für Therapie nutzen also gibt
es von dem innovationsvor und der
Krebshilfe geförderte Projekte die die
gesamte Versorgungslandschaft
zusammenfassen sollen und gleichzeitig
an den Daten forschen sollen weil wir
die Behandlung die nächste Generation
bringen möchten neue Konzepte und
verstehen warum ein Patient anspricht
der andere nicht oder bei älteren
Patienten die Behandlungen wirken bei
jüngeren schlechter und so weiter
und um dieses Projekt zu aktivieren
überhaupt anzufangen haben die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter erstmal
eineinhalb bis zwei Jahre daran
gearbeitet die 18 unterschiedlichen
landesdatenschützer in den verschiedenen
Einrichtungen die datenschutzer an den
universitätskliniker bei den Landes- und
sonstigen Ärztekammern mitzunehmen und
zu überzeugen dass man hier eine
Verknüpfung versuchen könnte zwischen
einem kleinen Teil von versorgungsdaten
und von
Forschungsdaten das heißt zwei Jahre in
dem Geld ausgegeben wird und das
irgendetwas nützliches passiert außer
Bürokratie zu bewältigen und deswegen
müssen wir hier schneller werden zweiter
Punkt wir haben analysiert bei der
Bewerbung für das nationale
Tumorzentrums Programm das Deutschland
im Vergleich zu allen westlichen
Industrienationen in der Krebsforschung
zurückgefallen ist wir setzen keine
eigene Ideen mehr um sondern wir haben
tatsächlich ein Boden verloren obwohl
eines der reichsten Länder sind pro Kopf
aber wir sind schlecht was eigene
Ideenentwicklung aus Deutschland in die
Anwendung angeht und das können wir als
als Wirtschaftsnation nicht leisten ich
glaube aber vor allem das können wir uns
nicht für unsere Patienten leisten
deshalb
ist dieses Anliegen für uns wichtig aber
man könnte nun sagen da soll der
Datenschutz geschliffen werden ja also
jetzt geht es sozusagen freie Fahrt weil
wir im Prinzip die Daten haben wollen
für Forschung und da werden Sie
überrascht sein wenn ich Ihnen sage
genau das Gegenteil in den aktuellen
kleinen kleinstlösungen der
Krankenhäuser sind häufig in Silos die
Daten durch mehr oder weniger kluge
datenexperten geschützt aber sie sind
nicht perfekt geschützt wir würden eine
bessere Sicherheit fordern sie müssen
professionell behandelt werden das heißt
wir brauchen stärkere professionellen
Umgang mit unseren Daten in den Lösungen
die dann gleichzeitig den Austausch
erlauben dann werden Sie sagen das ist
schwierig die technischen Lösungen kenne
ich nicht aber der Sachverständigenrat
hat sich Lösungen angeschaut in Ländern
ist sehr gut machen Estland z.B wo es in
den sogenannte blockchain-technik gibt
verstehe nicht so viel davon mit der man
ganz gut überprüfen kann wer sich in ein
System einlegt und das dann auch
sanktionieren kann wenn es
missbräuchlich passiert also es gibt
Lösungen wir müssen uns diese Aufgabe
stellen sonst fallen wir weiter zurück
und ist auch nicht einzusehen dass
Bürgerinnen und Bürger bei
gesundheitsanfragen Google
bereitwilligst jede Information zur
Verfügung stellen wenn sie sich
Informationen erwarten aber wenn wir
daran aus dem Solidarsystem forschen
wollen um die Behandlungen hier zu
verbessern und zu verstehen wo
Verschwendung beginnt und sinnvolle
Maßnahmen dass wir dann die Daten nicht
nutzen können weil wir uns selbst hören
aufbauen das soll hier verbessert werden
und deswegen bin ich froh dass diese
Maßnahmen jetzt angegangen werden was
aber auch wollen das ganz kurz zum
Schluss eine mehr und bessere einfachere
Datennutzung verkürzt Daten müssen vom
Missbrauch geschützt werden und zwar
professioneller als jetzt aber Sie
müssen in hellen helfen die Hände und
Forschung gelangen dürfen das dürfen wir
nicht weiter aktiv verhindern das ist
meine mein Fazit und deswegen bin ich
froh dass die sich Initiative jetzt so
entschlossen von der Bundesregierung und
den Ministerium angegangen wird vielen
Dank wir kommen zu ihren Fragen die
erste Frage geht an den Stein
hier hinten falls Sie Augenkontakt
aufnehmen wollen Herr Lauterbach wenn
ich das jetzt richtig verstehe Herr
Hallig hat es ja gerade ausgeführt so
ein bisschen beim Thema Datenschutz
Streben hier einige Veränderungen an in
der Pressemitteilung habe ich auch
gerade gesehen dass sie unter anderem
eine Veränderung bei der Stellung von
BSI und BfDI anstreben die wirkt auf
mich zumindest erst einmal so als ob es
eine Schwächung der Position von denen
wäre vielleicht können Sie diesen Punkt
schließen einfach erstmal erläutern dann
würde ich gegebenenfalls Nachfrage
stellen
ja vielen Dank nein in der Tat was hier
vorgesehen ist dass eben die
Entscheidungen auf mehr und breitere
Schultern verlagert werden und das ist
somit kommen dann beispielsweise auch
Mediziner zum Tragen also wie wichtig
ist das so was Bedeutung der Daten
einschätzen können also die medizinische
Wertigkeit von Daten ist ja schwieriger
einzuschätzen kommen schon Mediziner zum
Tragen kommen noch andere Experten zum
Tragen aber dann auch BSE und BFD also
sind dann auch mit dabei aber was stimmt
ist dass es also diese also so
klassische ich sag mal veto-rechte
im Sinne eines also
eines einfach Nehmens das wäre dann
nicht mehr zu erwarten sondern es sind
breite aufgestellt aber also BSE sind
mit dabei
ja dann doch die Nachfrage direkt dazu
was bewegt sie zu diesem Schritt denn
bis dann hatte ich das Gefühl dass für
die medizinische Seite der Sachverstand
nie angezweifelt wurde und das BSI und
BfDI in ihren Bereichen sachverständlich
sind vermutlich auch nicht an also warum
jetzt dieser Schritt hin dazu dass die
nur noch mit beraten sind und diese
vetorechnet nicht mehr haben soll
ja es ist also die Frage ob
beispielsweise also
wir hier nicht besser aufgestellt sind
wenn wir eine so also
komplexe
Materie in einem Verbund von Experten
entscheiden das ist dann ja eine
Verbesserung der Qualität es ist dann ja
nicht so dass also der bfti z.B nicht
mehr dabei wäre sondern ist ja noch da
ist er mit dabei also wird das Ganze
etwas breiter aufgestellt ich glaube mit
dieser etwas breiteren Aufstellung
gewinnen wir also beides Qualität und
Zeit
machen ja vielen Dank Lisa braun
Presseagentur Gesundheit erstmal habe
ich noch nicht ganz verstanden wann wir
mit den beiden Gesetzentwürfen konkret
rechnen können also wann was wann das
was zu lesen gibt und nicht nur
Strategien davon haben wir schon so
viele bekommen wird das gdng
sicherstellen dass die zahlreichen
unterschiedlichen Bundesland Auslegung
der DGSv oder dann harmonisiert werden
ist die eine Frage
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragter ist schon
gefallen ob der mit an Bord ist und
werden die Vorschläge der Bundesländer
aus dem letzten Jahr ich denke
insbesondere in Bayern und
Baden-Württemberg berücksichtigt werden
und eine Frage noch an den Klinik halt
Professor Alex Deutschland ist sie
hatten schon gesagt abgerutscht von
Platz zwei auf Platz sechs in relativ
kurzer Zeit
glauben Sie dieses Gesetz dieses gdng
wird das Zeug dazu haben das wieder zu
verbessern und zu heilen und uns wieder
auf einen besseren Platz zu spielen
dankeschön
ja vielen Dank beide Gesetze sind sehr
weit und werden in den nächsten Wochen
also vorgestellt
die finden es finden derzeit noch
entsprechende also Abstimmungen statt
aber also in den
Grundzügen sind also da sind beide
Gesetze formuliert und werden in den
nächsten Wochen ihnen vorgestellt werden
können es ist so mit also das was wir
machen ist nicht da so die Ankündigung
also eine
Strategie allein sondern im Wesentlichen
sind die beiden
Kernelemente digitalgesetz und
Gesundheitsdaten nutzungsgesetz sind
gerade weitgehend fertig und daher wird
es demnächst also vorgelegt was sie
Bundesländer angeht
ideal wäre wenn die Kriterien für die
also für die also ethische also
Bewertung eines Studie in allen
Bundesländern identisch wäre das wäre
ideal das haben wir aber nur also
indirekt also in der Hand weil wir
können darauf nur indirekt einwirken es
wäre aber definitiv so ein Schritt nach
vorne was wir hier machen können und
kollegahik alles gesagt wir ermöglichen
hat dass also einfach nur eine einzige
Genehmigung notwendig ist damit das dann
damit das Projekt die Studie
deutschlandweit stattfinden kann das ist
ein wichtiger Schritt nach vorne weil
also die diese vielen unterschiedlichen
Anforderungen das kostet sehr viel Zeit
und bringt wirklich ÜBERHAUPT keinen
Sicherheit gewinnen
Herr Kollege in dem dahinten bitteschön
ich verspreche mir davon ein
wesentlichen Effekt das eines der
zentralen Probleme der Krebsforschung
ich hatte schon gesagt sind wir sogar
nicht nur ein sechster Stelle sondern
unter den Wesen die Industrie Nationen
Europas auch Vergleich China und USA
Kanada mit dabei vor allem der letzten
Plätze bezogen auf das pro-kopfeinkommen
in Deutschland das heißt also wir sind
wirklich schlecht insbesondere dann wenn
es um aus der Akademie oder aus dem
eigenen Land entwickelten Präparaten
geht und wenn wir so weitermachen dann
bleiben wir sag mal etwas überspitzt so
eine Art abwurfland für Innovationen aus
anderen Ländern im Gesundheitswesen der
testforschung also wir kriegen dann die
teuren amerikanischen körperpakete der
Produkte die wir importieren müssen zu
hohen Kosten und wenn wir nicht anfangen
selber zu entwickeln dann wird das so
bleiben und ich glaube das können wir
uns nicht leisten warum glaube ich dass
es hier angreifen wird dieses Gesetz
oder dieses Vorhaben weil die
Beschleunigung der Verfahren ist für den
Forscher eines der wesentlichen
Hindernisse wir sind ja nicht dafür
ausgebildet worden oder geschult worden
Genehmigungsverfahren in allen
Bundesländern und dann auch noch mit zum
Teil widersprüchlichen bescheiden der
Datenschützer die sicher einander
widersprechen oft zu bearbeiten sondern
wir wollen im Prinzip Dinge voranbringen
und das hat schon einen hohen Anreiz
diese Beschleunigung hatten ganz hohen
Anreiz die Dinge besser zu machen
außerdem glaube ich haben ein
prinzipielles Problem was vielleicht gar
nicht so stark besprochen wurde nämlich
diese Primärdaten aus der Versorgung sie
werden gut in Erinnerung haben wie wenig
eigene Daten wie in der corona-pandemie
hatten und dass wir ständig nach England
und nach Israel und irgendwo sonst
hinschauen mussten um zu verstehen
bekommt man longkow wird auch mit wie
viel Impfungen dazu Null eigene Daten
aus der eigenen Versorgung hatten und
das ist immer noch so das heißt wir
müssen ein System schaffen wo wir aus
der eigenen Versorgung lernen wir mal
den Begriff Wissen generierende
Versorgung geprägt und dass die Routine
Versorgung in diese Daten mit einfließen
darf was momentan so gut wie unmöglich
ist damit wir nicht wieder in den
nächsten Pandemie oder in der Pandemie
der Krebserkrankung praktisch lernen
müssen durch Daten andere Länder also
ich hoffe mir ganz eindeutig davon in
ganz starken Schub und ich sag's
umgekehrt wenn es nicht kommt dann bin
ich pessimistisch dass wir den Abschluss
halten im Bereich der Medizin aber
vielleicht sogar als Wirtschaft davon
ja Lauterbach ich würde das Thema ganz
gerne auf das Oberthema Gesundheit und
Pflege etwas weiten und wenn sie
gestanden Fragen es gibt eine
umfangreiche Pflege Petition die im
Ministerium auch vom Petitionsausschuss
vorgelegt wurde ich meine da wäre auch
irgendwann in diesen Tagen Stichtag
Inhalt ist so ein bisschen der Ruf nach
konkreten Maßnahmen um die Lage in der
Pflege zu verbessern und wollte
eigentlich nur wissen können Sie mal
darstellen wo man bei dieser Petition
eigentlich gerade steht und welche
welche Maßnahmen ergreifen kann
vielleicht inklusive und auch abgesehen
von Digitalisierung um die Lage in der
Pflege kurzfristig zu verbessern ja
vielen Dank also was hier für uns
natürlich im Vordergrund steht
ist also das Pflegegesetz welches wird
derzeit ja also machen und also dort
werden also
die Leistungen der Pflege dynamisiert
und also gleichzeitig also die
Beiträge also angepasst insbesondere
auch in Bezug auf die Frage wie viele
Kinder hat jemand aber tatsächlich die
Dynamisierung der Leistungen in Rahmen
der jetzt also vorliegenden
Pflegereform das ist aus meiner Sicht
die wichtigste Antwort also auf diesen
auf diese Probleme
wenn ich noch nachfragen darf an einen
kurzfristigen Maßnahmen was was bringt
da Digitalisierung und wo endet
Digitalisierung und wo müssen wir dann
sagen okay da geht es um das Berufsbild
da geht es um mehr Geld um attraktiver
machen und so weiter ja ich sagte ja
schon dass das Pflegegesetz was wir
jetzt machen also nicht die
Digitalisierung das wird der kurzfristig
das kommt dann ja
kurzfristig dazu dass es also höheres
Pflegegeld gibt dass es also
höhere also Beträge gibt also für die
pflegefachleistungen dass es äh bessere
Zuschläge gibt für diejenigen die in der
stationären Pflege versorgt werden das
ist ein entlastungsbudget gibt was also
auch gefordert worden ist gekommen ist
jetzt also somit diese Entlastungen
darin sehe ich den also den Wert also
der Reform und die also Digitalisierung
ist auch eine Pflege sehr wichtig aber
hat er eine langfristige Bedeutung
ARD was sagt denn der
Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte zu ihren
Plänen kann ihm ja vielleicht nicht
alles gefallen vielleicht können Sie das
noch mal konkretisieren und die zweite
Frage was passiert wenn jemand der
Ehepaar widerspricht die wird dann gar
nicht angelegt im Hintergrund wenn
jemand aktiv widerspricht oder was genau
passiert da
zunächst aber die Gespräche mit dem
Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten finden
regelmäßig statt und so auf der
Fachebene meines Hauses also ist das
also ein gutes ein ständiges Gespräch
gar keine Frage und wir werden uns
natürlich also auch was jeden einzelnen
Teil also diese Gesetze angeben auch
auseinandersetzen
dass also
das das läuft geregelt und gut und ja es
ist tatsächlich so wenn ich jetzt der
Einsetzung einer Ehepaar für mich selbst
aktiv widerspreche dann wird keine EPA
für mich angelegt
wollen bis Ende 20 25 80 Prozent der
gesetzlichen Versicherten wollen Sie
dass die eine Patientenakte haben mit
wie viel Widerstand rechnen sie denn von
Seiten der Patientinnen und Patienten
wenig muss ich sagen weil die
allermeisten werden ja wahrscheinlich
froh wenn es diese Möglichkeit gibt dass
die Daten Ihre Daten gespeichert werden
wo sie dann erstmalig übrigens dann
selbst auch Zugang haben und man so
erwartet davon ja eine Verbesserung der
Versorgung es hat ja wenn man so will
also keine
Nachteile sondern nur Vorteile von daher
gehe ich davon aus dass die allermeisten
also hier schlicht zustimmen wird
also was ein bisschen an Indikator für
die Bereitschaft sein könnte
bei der Einführung in Österreich da
haben nur ungefähr drei Prozent
widersprochen
97 Prozent sind mitgezogen und ich
glaube daher da man selbst nichts machen
muss ist allerdings danach also so ist
dass der Arzt oder dass die mich
behandelnden Ärzte tatsächlich die Daten
nie für die Versorgung notwendig sind
auch immer haben das werden die
allermeisten mitmachen ich spiele in der
Praxis wirklich eine riesenrolle muss
ich sagen
beispielsweise ich war jetzt also
indirekt also in einem Zeitplanung also
Problem einbezogen da ging es immer eine
junge Frau die hatte Multiple Sklerose
und es waren etwas un also
ungewöhnlicher Erfahrung und für die
Kollegen die Zweitwohnung dann gemacht
haben wurde ich damit beschäftigt haben
war problematisch dass ein Teil der
Befunde einfach nicht da war die Frau
hatte die Bewohner nicht es waren
Untersuchungen gemacht worden aber
niemand hatte sie hatte die Befunde
nicht niemand hatte und dann steht da ja
wie im Vordergrund so so Veränderung in
Punkt und so weiter aber niemand hat den
Vordergrund das ist natürlich dass ich
ehrlich gesagt
nicht und diese vor Befunde wenn sie
nicht mehr gefunden werden die sind ja
auch weg in dem Sinne und mit einer
Ehepaar wäre das also nicht passiert
ich bin darauf hin dass ich ein lange
Latte von Fragen habe deswegen werden
sie nicht nervös wenn sie nicht sofort
dran kommen wir machen hier vorne weiter
Steffen von ZEIT ONLINE Lauterbach wenn
man bei Ärzten anruft oder auch bei der
bei der KBV heißt es im Moment EPAs für
uns kein Thema das nutzt keiner deswegen
beschäftigt uns das gar nicht ist das
dieser Defätismus von dem sie
vorhineingangssprachen das hat mich
aufhorchen lassen erklären sie noch mal
ein bisschen genauer was wie die
Einstellung in der Ärztinnen und Ärzte
da ist oder was sie da finden Probleme
sind und möglicherweise kann alle die
zweite Frage beantworten
ist denn in dem künftigen Gesetz oder
den Gesetzen vorgesehen die
Vorteile auszuräumen die Smartphone
Nutzer bisher hatten bei der Ehepaar
bzw wie sieht denn ihre Wunsch Lösung
für den Zugang aus also ich nehme warm
man braucht an Kartenlesegerät ein
online
-fähigen Personalausweis oder eine
spezielle Karte der Krankenkasse die
Frage ist wer sagt diesen wer macht
diesen Aufwand wenn man das doch mit dem
Smartphone eigentlich viel einfacher
hatten per Fingerprint sich autorisieren
kann etwas genauer interessieren
ja tatsächlich
hat sich in der Ärzteschaft aber nicht
nur dort ein
Defätismus breit gemacht
es ist mittlerweile so lange schon über
die elektronische Patientenakte uns
wartungsfort geredet worden ohne dass
viel passiert wäre dass viele das
Projekt aufgegeben haben einfach sagen
das kommt nicht mehr das wird das
erleben wir nicht mehr es kommt einfach
nicht mehr und dem begegnen wir jetzt
eben mit einer schnellen Umsetzung und
vor allen Dingen mit einer Umsetzung wo
sehr viel automatisch läuft
jedes automatisch also Träger einer
elektronischen Patientenakte in auch in
diesem Bereich also Gesundheitsdaten
nutzen das Gesetz das bauen wir auf wir
bauen quasi einen Platz auf wo diese
Auswertungen gemacht werden können es
sind also tatsächlich ist Bemühungen die
Dinge schnell aber auch unbürokratisch
und komfortabel zu machen
vielleicht in kurzer Ergänzung also ich
bin jetzt nicht der Technik-Experte aber
kann sagen je einfacher und klarer die
Lösung ist und ohne großen Aufwand
zusätzlich desto besser also
Identifikationsverfahren die quasi über
fingerprinz sie haben das schon gesagt
funktionieren wir haben es natürlich
werden mir lieber als Vision man sollte
aber auch schon zur Kenntnis nehmen dass
es nicht im Interesse sämtlicher
Versorger ist und das ist ja eine
klassische Dilemma in dieser Debatte zu
elektronischen Patienten Akten über
Jahrzehnte schon hier komplette
Transparenz aller Daten herzustellen
dass wir das für die Patienten tun
müssen und dass die Patienten übrigens
auch in Umfragen die wir gemacht haben
das in der Mehrheit unterstützen wir
haben Umfragen bei Krebspatienten 80 90
Prozent würden das wünschen das ist die
eine Seite und jetzt müssen eben die
versorge diesen Wunsch erfüllen und uns
bemühen dann Lösungen zu schaffen die
praktisch umsetzbar sind und da hilft
technische Einfachheit also mein Wunsch
wäre wiederholt so simpel wie möglich so
dass man keine aufwändigen
Registrierungsverfahren hat sondern mit
den üblichen Identifikationssystem die
in der Industrie dafür geprägt sind gute
Nachfrage ja
[Musik]
wäre sie eine Lösung wie das in
Österreich zum Beispiel ist dass man
einfach die Handynummer eingibt online
im Browser und dann noch mal über zwei
Faktor Authentifizierung sich dann
legitimiert in gangbarer Weg so dass
Nutzer um diese Kartenlösung irgendwie
rumkommen können die glaube ich schon
nicht unerhebliche Hürde wäre da würde
ich ihn viel mehr also prinzipiell recht
geben ich würde mir nicht anmaßen jetzt
die technischen Unterschiede da bewerten
zu wollen aber sie haben komplett Recht
die Mehraufwand meine in der Praxis z.B
betreiben muss und das Schaf zu schalten
desto höher wird er Widerstand sein und
jedes System was zum Teil von den
meisten Patienten selber z.B aktiviert
werden kann wäre besser
ja
also wir führen eine gesundheits-id ein
und diese Gesundheit äh die kann dann
genutzt werden um sich also entsprechend
zu registrieren und wenn das also dann
passiert ist zum Beispiel auf dem
eigenen Smartphon was sie gerade
beschrieben haben dann können dann noch
ganz klassische also biometrische Daten
genutzt werden somit es soll sozusagen
sehr simpel sein aber wichtig ist dass
wir zunächst einmal einen also sicheren
Zugang finden
[Musik]
wir machen in der Mitte weiter Frau
Kollegin bitteschön
Angelika Slavik von der Süddeutschen
Zeitung Herr Minister vielleicht könnten
Sie zum einen erklären wie kommt denn
meine bisherige Krankengeschichte in die
in die ePaper wer tut die da rein soll
ich das selber machen macht dass man
Hausarzt
und ist es denn so dass sie sagten sie
wollen Datensilos auflösen und die Daten
zusammenführen ist dass das einzige was
ich ändert oder ist auch die Gesamtmenge
der Daten die erhoben werden also steigt
danke
ja in der Tat also wenn ihre Stadt
gehabt dann Daten also irgendwie geladen
werden sondern wäre eine Möglichkeit
dass der also Hausarzt das macht
da ich muss sagen das ist noch nicht
also wirklich
komplett durchdacht ist wer da alles
helfen kann also man kann sich der
unterschiedliche Dinge vorstellen somit
das ist zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt also kann
ich kann ich das noch nicht sagen aber
es ist ganz klar also wichtiges Thema
denn also die Daten die es gab die ja
hochzuladen einzuscannen und so weiter
und so fort das würde sehr viel Sinn
machen und ähm wie wir das aber jetzt
machen also es ist unklar
man will die Hausärzte ja damit auch
nicht überlasten also man könnte sich
auch andere Möglichkeiten überlegen aber
da sind wir wirklich noch nicht hoch
noch nicht
und die Frage nach der Datenmenge ja die
Datenmengen wird hoffentlich zunehmen
also wenn wir hier also in der Situation
sind dass wir beispielsweise
Registerdaten demnächst also verknüpfen
können wir bekommen Genom Daten ich
hatte eben schon darauf hingewiesen die
wir derzeit noch nicht haben was
aufgebaut werden soll wir also hätten
dann die klassischen Daten also aus der
die Abrechnungsdaten der Krankenkasse
aber auch die Daten also die aus der Eva
selbst kommen und somit auch so
entstehen dann ja jeden Tag zusätzliche
Daten weil auch die Eva Daten
laufen dann ja in das System hinein wo
ich also im
Gesundheitsdaten nutzungsgesetz diese
Ausrichtung machen kann das ist aber
dann auch sehr einflussreich Kollege
Halle hat es eben schon gesagt also das
ist keine Kleinigkeit wenn man diese
Daten hat oder nicht
wir also beraten uns ein bisschen oder
werden ein bisschen wir werden beraten
oder sind im Gespräch mit den also
digitalexperten in Israel und dort hat
man über eine elektronische
Patientenakte im klarlit also System
also gleich Kasse hat man sehr schnell
erkennen können das war spektakulär das
70% der Corona Toten sich aus einer
Gruppe von 7% Risiko Trägern also
zusammensetzen und da hat man das wusste
hat man diese sieben Prozent ganz
gezielt
angesprochen und zuerst geimpft und das
hat einen enormen Unterschied gemacht
das hat einfach das war einfach enorme
Unterschied nachher hat man gesehen aus
diesen Daten und das also
die das passt so wird das Risiko also zu
sterben also bestimmte Gruppen um 80%
behindern
die automatisch also ohne Zustimmung
also nutzbar sind keine personenbezogene
Daten aber sonst ist das so ja
ja also
meinetwegen also wenn jetzt ausgewertet
wird also
wie viele Patienten in Deutschland gibt
es also mit einer bestimmten
Krebserkrankung
bitte Frau Kolleginnen leider haben wir
kein Mikrofon davon in der falschen
Reiber hinter ihnen Mikrofon
voll vom gesundheitspolitischen
Informationsdienst ich habe einmal die
Frage wenn es sich doch um
pseudonymisierte Daten handelt also auch
die die aus der EPA rausgehen wie können
Sie dann die Personen ansprechen und
identifizieren die beispielsweise für
eine bestimmte Studie in Frage kämen wie
sie ja vorhin als Beispiel genannt haben
und die zweite Frage ist die ich habe
woher nehmen sie die Zuversicht das
große internationale Unternehmen wieder
aufgrund dieser Gesetze nach Deutschland
in der Forschung zurückkehren weil sie
das Beispiel bayern-tech nannten weil ja
in England oder in Amerika der
Datenschutz immer wesentlich geringer
ist als hier in Europa und speziell auch
in Deutschland ich denke zum Beispiel
daran dass der nhls ja mit der einer
Google-Tochter einen Vertrag
abgeschlossen hatte über die Nutzung von
Patientendaten was käme jawohl hier in
Deutschland nicht in Frage
ja also die
Identifikation und auch Ansprache von
einzelnen Patienten ist auf der
Grundlage der pseudonymisierten Daten
natürlich nicht möglich dass es gar
keine Frage und also es wäre nur in
einer besonderen Notsituation
wäre es hier also möglich dass man also
einzelne Patienten also
anspricht und das könnte dann über den
Hausarzt zum Beispiel geschehen der die
also Patientendaten ja entsprechend
hätte wenn sie vom Patienten Fragen sind
aber tatsächlich die pseudonymisierten
Daten selbst können dafür nicht genutzt
werden
und
die also Frage nach also wie geht das
denn weiter also kommt niemand zurück
und so ja wir müssen uns einfach
tatsächlich der Herausforderung stellen
und es ist eine große Herausforderung
ich glaube trotzdem also Deutschland ist
das eigentlich also was also mehr
medizinische Forschung angeht ein also
besonders innovatives Land hat also sehr
also gute Wissenschaftler und auch sehr
gute Grundlage Wissenschaftler somit ist
es ist eigentlich ein interessanter
Standort und von daher kann ich mir sehr
gut vorstellen dass es so viele Firmen
gibt die dann also diesen großen
Standort mit also viel Wissenschaft aber
auch also mit mit vielen Patienten also
das
kann interess ant sein also das ist dann
schon möglich aber es wird nicht leicht
werden
ja soweit also unser Gesundheitsminister
Karl Lauterbach zum Neustart der
elektronischen Patientenakte wir alle
sollen in naher Zukunft eine solche
bekommen außer man widerspricht
ausdrücklich wir sehen uns wenn Sie
mögen um 12 Uhr wieder mit neuen
Nachrichten und um 13 Uhr übertragen wir
die Auftaktveranstaltung zum Synodalen
Weg in Frankfurt das ist die letzte
Etappe dieses großen Reformprozesses der
katholischen Kirche